Jake: 还没解封
Jake: It hadn't been lifted
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Lucia: 所以就是我当时被相当于封在上海
Lucia: So I was basically stuck in Shanghai
Lucia: 去不了别的地方一段时间
Lucia: Couldn't go anywhere for a while
Lucia: 然后这段时间在上海找了一个武士
Lucia: Then during that time, I found a martial arts instructor in Shanghai
Lucia: 然后就是那会是吧
Lucia: And then, you know
Jake: 是是在一个小区还是
Jake: Was it in a residential area or...
Lucia: 本来本来想学一下
Lucia: At first, I wanted to learn
Jake: 不是小区不能出
Jake: Weren't you unable to leave the residential area?
Lucia: 是小区就是他
Lucia: Yes, it was in the residential area, but he...
Lucia: 是舞房的话
Lucia: If it was a dance studio
Lucia: 一般他都购物中心里面
Lucia: Usually, it's inside a shopping mall
Jake: 哦这样子OK
Jake: Oh, I see. Okay.
Lucia: 然后就是我
Lucia: So then I...
Lucia: 我本来想去试一下学那个
Lucia: I originally wanted to try learning that
Lucia: 我当时报了一个swag还是breaking的课
Lucia: I signed up for a swag or breaking class at the time
Jake: 哎呀你这也没电了
Jake: Oh no, you're out of battery
Lucia: 然后跳了两三节之后我发现不行
Lucia: After two or three classes, I realized I couldn't do it
Lucia: 我跳不动
Lucia: I couldn't keep up
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Lucia: 然后我就放弃了
Lucia: So I gave up
Katrina:  我们我报的那个hip Hop班
Katrina: The hip hop class I signed up for
Katrina:  我是报通卡
Katrina: I got an all-access pass
Katrina:  就是什么班都能跳
Katrina: So I could attend any class
Katrina:  然后他这是
Katrina:  他是基本不教那种片段舞
Katrina: They basically don't teach dance routines
Jake: 你这个是没电了
Jake: You're out of battery
Katrina:  就是只练基本功
Katrina: It's just basic skills practice
Lucia: 那那很好
Lucia: That's good
Katrina:  对有一点点但是会有一点点枯燥
Katrina: Yeah, but it can be a bit boring
Lucia: 对有一点点
Lucia: Yeah, a little
Katrina:  然后像爵士这种
Katrina: And for jazz...
Alice: 你的线呢宝
Alice: Where's your cable, babe?
Jake: 没电了就是单纯的没电插上
Jake: It's just out of battery, just plug it in
Lucia: 但是我觉得很好看
Lucia: But I think it looks nice
Lucia: 但是我感觉我自己好像不是很漂亮
Lucia: But I feel like I don't look very pretty doing it
Katrina:  但是你你学
Katrina: But if you learn...
Tasha: 有电了吗
Tasha: Is it charged now?
Katrina:  还挺顺的
Katrina: It's pretty smooth.
Jake: 没有你要setup一下
Jake: No, you need to set it up first.
Tasha:  Complete
Tasha: Complete.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 哦yes好
Jake: Oh yes, good.
Tasha: blue 蓝牙连接失败
Tasha: Bluetooth connection failed.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Alice: 看个什么玩吧
Alice: What should we watch?
Alice: 你也无聊可以跟我分享一下吗
Alice: If you're bored, can you share something with me?
Tasha:  分享什么
Tasha: Share what?
Alice: 看看你的视频
Alice: Show me your videos.
Katrina:  就我一个同学找工作呢
Katrina: Just a friend of mine is looking for a job.
Katrina:  他他一个offer在长沙一个在苏州
Katrina: He got one offer in Changsha and one in Suzhou.
Tasha: 随便
Tasha: Whatever.
Katrina:  他在纠结去哪
Katrina: He's struggling to decide where to go.
Jake: 消费也不一样
Jake: The cost of living is different.
Alice: 妈呀看不懂
Alice: Oh my, I don't understand.
Katrina:  对苏州那是要比长沙
Katrina: Yes, Suzhou is more expensive than Changsha.
Tasha: 我来教你
Tasha: I'll teach you.
Katrina:  他你知道他今年考研
Katrina: You know he took the postgraduate exam this year.
Katrina:  他他出了分数以后
Katrina: After he got his scores...
Alice: 这么多人都在看
Alice: So many people are watching.
Katrina:  他觉得自己文考不上你知道吗
Katrina: He thought he wouldn't pass, you know?
Tasha: 对现在还有这么多人
Tasha: Yes, there are still so many people.
Katrina:  结果
Katrina: But...
Katrina:  今年统计的分数比去年低了三四十分
Katrina: This year, the scores are 30-40 points lower than last year.
Lucia: 然后他考上了
Lucia: And he passed.
Tasha: 13号打的
Tasha: Took the exam on the 13th.
Katrina:  他其实考上了
Katrina: He actually passed.
Katrina:  但是他没有准备一点的复试
Katrina: But he didn't prepare for the second round at all.
Katrina:  他直接找工作去了
Katrina: He went straight to job hunting.
Katrina:  我靠今年真的很奇怪
Katrina: This year is really weird.
Jake: 那他后来准备了吗
Jake: Did he prepare later?
Katrina:  没准备复试
Katrina: No, he didn't prepare for the second round.
Katrina:  他直接没去复试他就找工作去了
Katrina: He skipped it and just went job hunting.
Katrina:  有点烦
Katrina: It's a bit annoying.
Lucia: 有点可惜
Lucia: It's a bit of a pity.
Lucia: 他应该就是
Lucia: He should have...
Lucia: 反正已经拿到复试机会了
Lucia: Since he already had the chance for the second round.
Jake: 对啊准备个一天吗
Jake: Yeah, are we preparing for a whole day?
Lucia: 就是跑的不太理想
Lucia: It's just that the run wasn't ideal.
Katrina:  但是但是他他出那个对好像统计
Katrina: But, but he, he put out that statistic.
Jake: 对啊是哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, right, hahaha.
Lucia: 说不定就是我了
Lucia: Maybe it's me.
Jake: 对啊卡拉OK
Jake: Yeah, karaoke.
Jake: 对一会修硕就卡拉OK回来了
Jake: Yeah, Shure will come back with karaoke later.
Katrina:  同济还不怎么删人呢
Katrina: Tongji doesn't really delete people.
Tasha: 我重新开了要读秒吗
Tasha: I restarted it, should we count down?
Jake: 要要
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 我们今天是不是还没读秒
Alice: Did we not count down today?
Tasha: 没读
Tasha: We didn't.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Katrina:  哦还有风花
Katrina: Oh, there's also Fenghua.
Katrina:  确实特别是这种有花苞的可以记录一下
Katrina: Especially those with buds can be recorded.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 看时间
Jake: Check the time.
Katrina:  我有个舍友天天看
Katrina: I have a roommate who watches every day.
Tasha: 真的吗对
Tasha: Really, right?
Katrina:  对他
Katrina: Yeah, he...
Katrina:  他会因为那些选手没打好而气得半死
Katrina: He gets so mad when the players don't perform well.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  这这他在宿舍又哭又笑的
Katrina: He laughs and cries in the dorm.
Katrina:  看总决赛的时候他看的
Katrina: Watching the finals, he...
Tasha: 哦他看的难道是LCK决赛
Tasha: Oh, was he watching the LCK finals?
Jake: 啊哈这么带劲
Jake: Ah, so intense.
Katrina:  难道是他就看英雄联盟
Katrina: Maybe he was watching League of Legends.
Tasha: 还是LPL吗
Tasha: Or was it the LPL?
Katrina:  我不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina:  他看好多
Katrina: He watches a lot.
Katrina:  对LPL他他都看
Katrina: Yeah, LPL, he watches all of it.
Alice: 你最喜欢谁啊
Alice: Who's your favorite?
Tasha: 我最喜欢的就是这支队伍的这个选手
Tasha: My favorite is this player from this team.
Alice: 这叫啥
Alice: What's his name?
Tasha: 他叫Cherry
Tasha: His name is Cherry.
Katrina:  他看他喜欢
Katrina: He likes...
Katrina:  那叫什么小花生
Katrina: What's his name, Peanut?
Katrina:  韩国的那个
Katrina: That Korean guy.
Tasha: enough
Tasha: Enough.
Katrina:  他叫他对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, him.
Katrina:  好像是他
Katrina: I think it's him.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我知道
Tasha: Hahaha, I know.
Katrina:  就是那个单眼皮那个他
Katrina: It's that single-eyelid guy.
Tasha: 特别帅的打野
Tasha: The really handsome jungler.
Katrina:  他就说他长得挺帅的
Katrina: He said he's quite handsome.
Tasha: Tina和我喜欢的Chovy
Tasha: Tina and I like Chovy.
Tasha: 昨去年是一支队伍的
Tasha: Last year, they were in the same team.
Tasha: 然后今年他们全部都转队了
Tasha: This year, they all transferred teams.
Alice: 我好像看到过很多次这个名字
Alice: I think I've seen that name a lot.
Tasha: Faker
Tasha: Faker.
Alice: 嗯看什么顶级的
Alice: Yeah, like some top-tier.
Katrina:  啊我也是
Katrina: Ah, me too.
Katrina:  Faker不是那个最有名的
Katrina: Isn't Faker the most famous?
Tasha: 他就是嗯
Tasha: He is, yeah.
Alice: 顶级打野吗
Alice: A top-tier jungler?
Tasha: 打野吗顶级中单
Tasha: Jungler? No, top-tier mid-laner.
Tasha: 他怎么说呢
Tasha: How should I put it...
Alice: 顶级中单
Alice: Top-tier mid-laner.
Tasha: 他特别厉害
Tasha: He's really amazing.
Tasha: 怎么说他现在就是已经30岁了
Tasha: How should I say, he's already 30 now.
Tasha: 一般选手在25岁就要退役了
Tasha: Most players retire at 25.
Tasha: 就是因为反应速度跟不上
Tasha: Because their reaction speed slows down.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 然后他在30岁这年
Tasha: But in his 30th year,
Tasha: 还拿了一个世界总冠军
Tasha: He won a world championship.
Tasha: 哇哦对
Tasha: Wow, right.
Tasha: 然后他人身上已经拿过三次冠军
Tasha: He's already won three championships.
Tasha: 这是第四次冠军
Tasha: This is his fourth.
Tasha: 很多人打了十年都没有过一次冠军
Tasha: Many people play for ten years without winning once.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: That's amazing.
Tasha: 对而且他是出道级巅峰吧
Tasha: Yeah, and he peaked right after debuting.
Tasha: 好像是15岁
Tasha: At like, 15.
Tasha: 然后高中
Tasha: During high school.
Tasha: 上初中还是上高中
Tasha: Was it middle school or high school?
Tasha: 的时候偶然间被发现了
Tasha: When he was discovered by chance.
Tasha: 然后就然后就被选中了
Tasha: Then he got selected.
Tasha: 然后就打比赛
Tasha: And started competing.
Tasha: 然后一打比赛
Tasha: Once he started competing,
Tasha: 就把当时的顶级中单
Tasha: He took down the top mid-laner at the time,
Tasha: 给一对一的杀掉了
Tasha: In a one-on-one.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing!
Tasha: 然后就一战成名
Tasha: And then instantly became famous.
Jake: 好过分啊
Jake: That's too much.
Jake: 哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake: 强到过分
Jake: So strong, it's too much.
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Tasha: 就是一出道就强盗过分
Tasha: Just too strong right from the start.
Tasha: 并且一直强了这么多年
Tasha: And has remained strong for so many years.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  昨天那个写名字的
Katrina: That guy who wrote his name yesterday.
Tasha: 而且他就是从来不买皮肤
Tasha: And he never buys skins.
Tasha: 就是不提倡大家买皮肤
Tasha: He doesn't encourage buying skins.
Tasha: 所以他在比赛还是平时的打
Tasha: So even in tournaments or regular games,
Tasha: 打游戏就只用棉皮
Tasha: He only uses default skins to play.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈好有意思
Alice: Hahahahaha, that's so interesting.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  我纯技术虐
Katrina: I beat people purely with skill.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Tasha: 好像说韩国90%的人只要玩英雄联盟
Tasha: It seems like 90% of people in Korea who play League of Legends
Tasha: 都是他的粉丝
Tasha: Are his fans.
Jake: 剩下10%嫉妒他是吗呵
Jake: The remaining 10% are just jealous of him, right? Haha.
Tasha: 男粉啊什么男生嫉妒他
Tasha: Male fans, yeah, some guys are jealous of him.
Tasha: 女生都很喜欢他
Tasha: But girls really like him.
Tasha: 而且保持着极高的职业素养
Tasha: And he maintains a very high level of professionalism.
Tasha: 到现在都没有谈过一场恋爱
Tasha: He hasn't been in a relationship up till now.
Tasha: 哇为就是为游戏奉献人生的感觉
Tasha: Wow, it feels like he's dedicating his life to the game.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 可以可以好厉害啊
Lucia: That's amazing, really impressive.
Tasha: 就
Tasha: Just...
Tasha: 尽管他们这支队伍现在就是比较差
Tasha: Even though their team is pretty bad now,
Tasha: 之前一段时间Faker他因为手受伤
Tasha: For a while, Faker had a hand injury,
Tasha: 他就暂时没有参加比赛
Tasha: So he temporarily didn't compete.
Tasha: 然后他们队连最弱的队伍都没有打过
Tasha: And then their team couldn't even beat the weakest teams.
Tasha: 就是十连败
Tasha: They lost ten games in a row.
Alice: 哈哈十连败
Alice: Haha, ten losses in a row.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后现在飞快
Tasha: Hahaha, and then now,
Tasha: 一上场就直接打总
Tasha: As soon as he came back, they immediately made it to the finals.
Lucia: carry全场
Lucia: Carried the whole team.
Tasha: 就直接打总决赛了都
Tasha: We're going straight to the finals.
Tasha: 他可能是队伍的一个核心大脑
Tasha: He might be the core brain of the team.
Tasha: 就那种偏指挥的
Tasha: Like the one in charge of command.
Tasha: 还有偏运营的都归他啊
Tasha: And also operations, he handles all that.
Alice: 他长哪个样子
Alice: What does he look like?
Tasha: 这是他们队的ad
Tasha: He's their AD.
Tasha: 因为现在在选ad位
Tasha: Because they're picking an AD now.
Tasha: 这个人长得是不是有点像杨戬
Tasha: Doesn't this guy look a bit like Yang Jian?
Tasha: 哈哈哈我当时看的时候
Tasha: Haha, when I saw him...
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  你写一下名字
Katrina: Write down the name.
Tasha: 就是那个宝莲灯里面的那个三眼狼
Tasha: Like the three-eyed wolf from the Lotus Lantern.
Katrina:  这选花吗
Katrina: Are we picking flowers?
Alice: 我给你写吧还是你写
Alice: Should I write it or you?
Alice: 写个啥呢
Alice: What should I write?
Alice: ok这是我
Alice: Okay, this is me.
Alice: 给你写啥
Alice: What should I write for you?
Tasha: 给我画个翅膀就行
Tasha: Just draw me some wings.
Alice: 天呐我的翅膀多丑
Alice: Oh my god, my wings look so ugly.
Tasha: 那个peanut
Tasha: That peanut.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha: 给你们看看LCK美男
Tasha: Let me show you the handsome guy from LCK.
Alice: 完了
Alice: Oh no.
Alice: 啊怎么办
Alice: Ah, what should we do?
Katrina: 你们稍微挑一下
Katrina: You guys pick a bit.
Alice: 怎么办哈哈哈
Alice: What should we do, hahaha.
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just go with this.
Tasha: 这个就是peanut
Tasha: This is peanut.
Alice: 给你加个爱心好了
Alice: I'll add a heart for you.
Tasha: 就是那个小花生
Tasha: It's the little peanut.
Katrina:  看看我看看是不是他
Katrina: Let me see if it's him.
Katrina:  抖音经常发的那个男人
Katrina: The guy often on Douyin.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Ah, haha.
Katrina:  是他我知道
Katrina: It's him, I know.
Tasha: 我知道
Tasha: I know.
Tasha: 很帅啦
Tasha: Very handsome.
Katrina:  我给你看他的抖音
Katrina: Let me show you his Douyin.
Katrina:  他每天都发这些的
Katrina: He posts these every day.
Tasha: 真的很帅的
Tasha: Really handsome.
Katrina:  他是是挺帅的
Katrina: He is quite handsome.
Tasha: 嗯是呃
Tasha: Um, yeah, uh
Tasha: 这种辅助型打野的代表了啊
Tasha: This kind of support jungler, you know
Tasha: 这个就是我喜欢的英雄
Tasha: This is my favorite hero
Jake: 这就是补刀不漏兵吗
Jake: So this is about last-hitting without missing any minions?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes
Jake: 是的哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, hahaha
Tasha: 一刀不漏呵呵
Tasha: Not missing a single last-hit, haha
Katrina:  他的抖音
Katrina: His Douyin
Katrina:  每天剪他的
Katrina: He edits it every day
Tasha: 他的哈哈哈
Tasha: His, hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Tasha: 他真的很可爱了
Tasha: He's really cute
Katrina:  哎对他就每天说
Katrina: Yeah, every day he says
Katrina:  你知道他有多可爱吗
Katrina: Do you know how cute he is?
Katrina:  我说谁都给你看
Katrina: I say, I'll show anyone
Tasha: 他谁啊好丑啊哈哈
Tasha: Who is he? He's so ugly, haha
Tasha: 哎这个是国内选手
Tasha: Hey, this is a domestic player
Lucia: 老师这是个混剪
Lucia: Teacher, this is a mashup
Lucia: 我以为是他的个人丧呢
Lucia: I thought it was his personal video
Tasha: 这个也是国内选手
Tasha: This one is also a domestic player
Alice: 为什么我感觉他又长得有点像那个谁
Alice: Why do I feel like he looks like that guy
Tasha: 刘青松
Tasha: Liu Qingsong
Alice: 不认识是那个
Alice: I don't know, that guy
Alice: 王
Alice: Wang
Tasha: 他已经算是
Tasha: He's already considered
Tasha: 国内就中国队的第一美男了
Tasha: The most handsome guy on the Chinese team
Alice: 刚刚那个长得好像那个
Alice: The one just now looks like that
Alice: 谁呀
Alice: Who?
Alice: 想不起来我难受
Alice: I can't remember, it's frustrating
Tasha: 这些我都不喜欢
Tasha: I don't like any of these
Tasha: 都很一般哈哈哈
Tasha: They're all pretty average, haha
Jake: 好开点外卖吧
Jake: Okay, let's order some takeout
Alice: 王王什么王
Alice: Wang, Wang, what Wang?
Jake: 点点外卖吧
Jake: Order some takeout
Tasha: and我觉得
Tasha: And I think
Alice: 王什么
Alice: Wang what?
Alice: 没事王什么来着
Alice: Never mind, what Wang?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Alice: 取消了
Alice: Forget it
Katrina:  点外卖还是啥
Katrina: Order takeout or what?
Jake: 点外卖
Jake: Order takeout
Katrina:  你挑一下自己的花纹
Katrina: Pick your own pattern
Tasha: 这款围很喜欢
Tasha: I really like this scarf
Jake: 挑花
Jake: Choose a pattern
Jake: 要不等修硕来
Jake: Or wait for Shure
Jake: 我们先把这一段给结了就结束吧
Jake: Let's finish this segment first and then wrap it up
Jake: 上午上午
Jake: Morning, morning
Alice: 点了是吗
Alice: Did you order it?
Jake: 就这样还没有点
Jake: Not yet
Alice: 不是啊对啊
Alice: No, right
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: Exactly
Jake: 关掉关掉关掉
Jake: Turn it off, turn it off
Alice: 这就是把这个点掉
Alice: Just turn this off
Katrina:  还有我们的舞蹈
Katrina: And our dance
Tasha: 什么点掉
Tasha: What to turn off
Alice: 就关掉要开始关了是吗对
Alice: Just turn it off, is it starting to shut down? Yes.
Tasha: 关掉关掉干嘛好
Tasha: Why turn it off? Fine.
Jake: 对关掉
Jake: Yes, turn it off
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh man
Alice: 关掉结束了
Alice: Turn it off, it's over
Tasha: 我在面对以后的研究人员
Tasha: I am facing future researchers
Katrina:  天呐感觉货到了那种
Katrina: Oh my god, feels like the goods have arrived
Tasha: 我说我们在欣赏电竞美男
Tasha: I said we are appreciating esports handsome guys
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice: 那就停了
Alice: Then just stop
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 嗯这是你的杯子吗
Lucia: Hmm, is this your cup?
Katrina:  我要泡种子
Katrina: I want to soak seeds
Katrina:  Complete
Katrina: Complete
Lucia: 它还是在充电它已经恢复了25%
Lucia: It's still charging, it has recovered 25%
Jake:嗯好没关系
Jake: Hmm, okay, no problem
Alice:我们来一个第一人称的
Alice: Let's do it in first person.
Alice:这样ASM哈哈哈
Alice: Like this, ASM hahaha.
Alice:欢迎来到
Alice: Welcome to
Alice:星星的
Alice: Star's
Alice:  呃呃直播化妆空间
Alice: Uh, uh, live makeup space.
Tasha: 喜欢听AMSR吗
Tasha: Do you like listening to AMSR?
Alice:我我每天都要听
Alice: I, I listen to it every day.
Tasha: 你每天都要听我也听
Tasha: You listen to it every day? Me too.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:开了吗别别别别开
Jake: Is it on? No, no, no, don't start.
Jake:早了早了
Jake: It's too early.
Jake:你已经开了啊
Jake: You already started it?
Tasha:开了
Tasha: It's on.
Alice:我们都开了
Alice: We're all live.
Jake:这个呃头发挡住了
Jake: This, uh, the hair is blocking it.
Lucia: 这很真实
Lucia: This is so real.
Lucia: 就是我们人类的头发也经常会打碎
Lucia: Our human hair often gets in the way too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:对对确实确实这样真实
Jake: Yes, yes, this is very real.
Jake:但是真的还是难度
Jake: But it's really difficult.
Jake:难度太高了搞不动
Jake: It's too hard to handle.
Alice:这是歌剧魅影吗
Alice: Is this The Phantom of the Opera?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:好用吗
Alice:好用我也买一个算了我不会遮瑕
Alice: If it's good, I'll buy one too, but I'm bad at concealing.
Tasha: 我嗯
Tasha: I, uh.
Tasha: 我的建议是
Tasha: My suggestion is...
Alice:我自己来吧
Alice: I'll do it myself.
Tasha: 什么你自己来我先
Tasha: What, you'll do it yourself? I'll start first.
Lucia: 我觉得等我回家
Lucia: I think when I get home,
Lucia: 我也得买一个这种大一点的化妆包
Lucia: I also need to get a bigger makeup bag.
Lucia: 我每次东西都放不下
Lucia: I can't fit all my stuff in.
Tasha: 好那我们第一步
Tasha: Okay, so our first step...
Alice:遮瑕
Alice: Concealer.
Tasha: 啊没有什么瑕算了黑眼圈
Tasha: Ah, there's nothing to conceal, forget it, just dark circles.
Jake: 第二步
Jake: Second step.
Lucia: 校准一下时间
Lucia: Adjust the time.
Jake: 对第二部校准一下
Jake: Yes, the second step is to adjust the time.
Alice:给他看这个
Alice: Show him this.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:我自己涂开吧嗯
Alice: I'll apply it myself, okay?
Lucia: 哎我又把我手机撂哪去了
Lucia: Oh, where did I leave my phone again?
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
Alice:素人改造计划启动
Alice: Ordinary people makeover project starts now
Alice:我一想到这是个摄像头
Alice: Just thinking about this being a camera
Alice:我现在有点难受
Alice: makes me feel a bit uncomfortable
Alice:有点不好意思
Alice: I feel a bit embarrassed
Tasha: 感觉这化妆刷也不是很好用
Tasha: I feel like this makeup brush isn't very good
Tasha: 为什么卖十几块钱一个
Tasha: Why does it cost over ten bucks each?
Alice:就这样直接粉底得了哎
Alice: Just apply the foundation directly, yeah
Alice:我也用了这个UKISS的这个这个，对
Alice: I also used this UKISS foundation, right
Tasha: 打底
Tasha: Primer
Alice:哦我懂了这个叫嗯什么提亮暗沉哦
Alice: Oh, I get it, this is for brightening dull skin, oh
Alice:只要手揉开就行了吧啊
Alice: Just rub it in with your hand, right?
Alice:哦这个是拇指
Alice: Oh, this is for the thumb
Alice:套是吧
Alice: It's a cover, right?
Alice:让外国人研究一下中国的
Alice: Let foreigners study some Chinese
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good
Jake: 满分数据我去
Jake: Full score data, wow
Alice:哇其他几个是啥来着
Alice: Wow, what are the other three again?
Tasha: 哦你稍微转过来一些
Tasha: Oh, turn a bit this way
Alice:其他几个是啥来着
Alice: What are the other three again?
Jake: 这是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 给你增加一些
Lucia: Adding some for you
我也不记得
I don't remember either
Lucia: 人类早期绘制猫咪的珍贵场面
Lucia: Precious scenes of early human depictions of cats
Jake: 哦临摹是吗
Jake: Oh, copying, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahaha, yes
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 现在在
Jake: Now in
Alice:这 叫面中提亮吗
Alice: Is this called mid-face highlighting?
Alice:是吗
Alice: Is it?
Tasha: 哦是吗
Tasha: Oh, is it?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Wow
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes
Alice:我懂但我不会
Alice: I get it but I can't do it
Jake: 有点专业的
Jake: A bit professional
Tasha: 你有点专业在身上呢
Tasha: You seem pretty professional.
Alice:但是我直接就第一步上粉底然后没了
Alice: But I just go straight to applying foundation and that's it.
Tasha: 但是我今天也没遮瑕
Tasha: But I didn't use any concealer today either.
Alice:我觉得太麻烦了
Alice: I think it's too much trouble.
直接上个粉底就完事
Just put on some foundation and be done with it.
Alice:鼻子有一点点塌
Alice: My nose is a bit flat.
Alice:我去度一下吧
Alice: I'll contour it a bit.
Alice:那都不必了
Alice: But it's not necessary.
Tasha: 但是我也不知道怎么把他画的很挺
Tasha: But I don't know how to make it look more defined.
Jake: 好多笔啊
Jake: So many pens.
Alice:我会一点点
Alice: I know a little bit.
Jake: 我也在找笔
Jake: I'm looking for a pen too.
Tasha: 找什么笔
Tasha: What kind of pen are you looking for?
Jake: 你能写什么笔
Jake: What can you write with?
Lucia: 哎刚才才那个那支笔
Lucia: Hey, where's that pen from earlier?
Lucia: 那个咱们用来写那个啥的画
Lucia: The one we use to draw that thing.
Jake: 是我自己
Jake: It was mine.
Jake: 有一只给我扔哪去了
Jake: I think I lost one somewhere.
Alice:去哪了
Alice: Where did it go?
Tasha: 嗯应该是没关系没什么可
Tasha: Hmm, it should be fine, nothing to worry about.
Lucia: 不对我把这个爪子画太长了
Lucia: No, I drew this claw too long.
Alice:可以到粉底了吗
Alice: Can we move on to the foundation?
Tasha: 可以了吧
Tasha: I think so.
Alice:你这是干皮的还是油皮的
Alice: Is your skin dry or oily?
Tasha: 干皮的
Tasha: It's dry.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Alice:无所谓就这样
Alice: Doesn't matter, just like this.
Alice:你是干皮吗
Alice: Is your skin dry?
Tasha: 我总感觉我帮你画的不好看
Tasha: I feel like I'm not doing a good job with your makeup.
Alice:没关系你不画也不好看
Alice: It's okay, it doesn't look good even if you don't do it.
Alice:我自己拍吧
Alice: I'll just do it myself.
Alice:是不没涂匀
Alice: Is it not even?
Tasha: 还算匀吧
Tasha: It's quite even, I think.
Alice:行
Alice: Alright.
Alice:再涂点
Alice: Apply a bit more.
Alice:每次都差不多用手把它
Alice: Every time, I just use my hands to...
Tasha: 我的妈
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 哈对不起
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Alice:就是涂的基本上就那啥
Alice: I just basically apply it like that.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Lucia: 他有那个什么吗
Lucia: Does he have that thing?
Alice:之后就稍微
Alice: Then just a little bit
Jake: 这这这
Jake: This, this, this
Tasha: 感觉挤太多了
Tasha: Feels like it's too crowded
Lucia: 啊啊sorry sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry, sorry
Alice:你来点
Alice: You do a bit
Jake: 没事
Jake: It's okay
Tasha: 哦我不了
Tasha: Oh, I'm not doing it
Lucia: 要命
Lucia: Oh my
Lucia: 我今天已经掉了第二次充电宝了
Lucia: I've dropped my power bank for the second time today
Tasha: 是挤的有点多
Tasha: It is a bit crowded
Jake: 没关系劲摔
Jake: It's okay, just drop it hard
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay
Alice:抹脖子
Alice: Put it on your neck
Jake: 抹脖子
Jake: Put it on your neck
Alice:给她抹点
Alice: Put some on her
Tasha:杨老师要来点吗
Tasha: Jake, do you want some?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 我哈哈哈
Jake: I hahaha
Jake: 啊抹哪
Jake: Where to put it?
Lucia: 是化点妆吗
Lucia: Is it makeup?
Alice:抹脸上
Alice: Put it on the face
Lucia: 要哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, haha
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 这化妆
Jake: This is makeup
Tasha: 眼镜摘下来吧
Tasha: Take off your glasses
Lucia: 这个这个充电宝稍微有点大
Lucia: This power bank is a bit big
Jake: 这么专业的
Jake: So professional
Lucia: 我口袋里放不下
Lucia: It doesn't fit in my pocket
Jake: 要不放椅子上啊
Jake: Why not put it on the chair?
Tasha: 啊粉扑帮您扑开
Tasha: Ah, let me help spread it with a puff
Lucia: 我可以把他用腿压住
Lucia: I can hold it with my leg
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow
Tasha: 然后说不要动
Tasha: Then say don't move
Tasha: 好美呀好美
Tasha: So beautiful, so beautiful
Tasha: 不要动不要眨眼睛哈哈
Tasha: Don't move, don't blink, haha
Alice: 我总感觉没弄匀就这样还有点
Alice: I always feel like it's not even, there's still a bit
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 杨老师你那胡子是不是该刮了
Tasha: Jake, should you shave your beard?
Jake: 嗯确实
Jake: Hmm, indeed.
Alice:抹匀了吗
Alice: Did you spread it evenly?
Alice:匀了吧
Alice: It's even, right?
Alice:美呀
Alice: Beautiful.
Tasha: 太美了杨老师
Tasha: So beautiful, Mr. Yang.
Alice: 太美了
Alice: So beautiful.
Jake: 是啊太美了
Jake: Yeah, it's really beautiful.
哈哈
laughter
Tasha: 太美了
Tasha: So beautiful.
Alice:太美了
Alice: So beautiful.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha: 直接白了3个多
Tasha: Instantly whiter by three shades.
Tasha: 您看一看
Tasha: Take a look.
Jake: 我看一看
Jake: Let me see.
Jake: 哈哈哈我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 啊太美了
Lucia: Ah, so beautiful.
Lucia: 哈哈哈肤质一下就变得特别好
Lucia: Hahaha, the skin looks so much better.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 不是不是以前也很好
Lucia: No, no, it was good before too.
Lucia: 就是更好了
Lucia: Just even better now.
Jake: 这么回事可以
Jake: That's what it is, okay.
Alice:匀了吧
Alice: It's even, right?
Tasha: 匀了
Tasha: Even.
Alice:就这吧下一步是睫毛
Alice: Let's move on to the eyelashes next.
Jake: 就是这就是什么
Jake: Is this... what?
Jake: 磨皮吗
Jake: Smoothing?
Tasha: 睫毛了已经
Tasha: Already on the eyelashes.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 腮红吧
Tasha: Blush next?
Alice:最后再腮红吧
Alice: Let's do blush last.
Alice:直接睫毛
Alice: Straight to eyelashes.
Tasha: 啊啊行
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Alice:我们是不是用了同款
Alice: Are we using the same brand?
Alice:v什么d什么安啊
Alice: V something, D something, A something?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:我用了红色
Alice: I used the red one.
Alice:好就这样贴
Alice: Okay, just stick it like this.
Alice:夹吧我来夹吧
Alice: Clip it, I'll do it.
Lucia: 擦了一下之后好不对称
Lucia: After wiping it, it's not symmetrical.
Tasha: 你要贴假睫毛吗
Tasha: Are you going to put on false eyelashes?
Alice:贴
Alice: Yes.
Tasha: 好你要用我的吗
Tasha: Okay, do you want to use mine?
Alice:我的假睫毛我不一定会用你
Alice: I have my own false eyelashes, I might not use yours.
Jake: 我们是不是有买笔这个环节
Jake: Do we have a segment where we buy a pen?
Alice:这是一条的吗
Alice: Is this a single one?
Jake: 买这个白板笔
Jake: Buying this whiteboard marker.
Lucia: 白板笔有这个环节吗
Lucia: Do we have a segment for whiteboard markers?
Jake: 我怎么记得昨天有这个
Jake: I remember we had this yesterday.
Alice:没用过这个
Alice: Never used this one.
Jake: 没有就算了
Jake: If not, it's okay.
Jake: 呵呵没有也可以买
Jake: Haha, we can still buy it even if we don't.
Tasha: 这个免胶
Tasha: This one doesn't need glue.
Alice:这个免胶我有胶
Alice: This one doesn't need glue, but I have glue.
Lucia: 打孔器和彩笔
Lucia: Hole puncher and colored pens.
Lucia: 哎确实有
Lucia: Oh, we do have it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但是已经有人在这里打了个勾
Lucia: But someone already checked it off here.
Tasha: 我也有叫
Tasha: I also have glue.
Lucia: 我不知道是不是
Lucia: I don't know if it's...
Jake: 好行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 到底用哪个
Tasha: Which one are we using?
Alice:你挑吧
Alice: You choose.
Tasha: 那就免胶的吧
Tasha: Then let's use the one without glue.
Alice:为什么是免胶呢
Alice: Why use the one without glue?
Alice:自己带的胶
Alice: I brought my own glue.
Tasha: 嗯它上面好像有那种胶吧
Tasha: Hmm, it seems to have some glue on it.
Alice:牢固吗
Alice: Is it secure?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Tasha: 我我都没拆包装呢
Tasha: I haven't even opened the package.
Alice:哎呀夹的不太好
Alice: Oh no, the clip isn't good.
Alice:这样吧
Alice: How about this?
Alice:行吗
Alice: Is it okay?
Tasha: 行行
Tasha: It's okay.
Alice:没夹差不多
Alice: Didn't clip it well, but close enough.
Alice:无所谓反正会贴
Alice: Doesn't matter, we'll stick it anyway.
Alice:嗯等一下睫毛打底
Alice: Hmm, wait a second, let's prime the lashes.
Alice:睫毛打底
Alice: Eyelash primer.
Tasha: 就觉得睫毛打底无所谓
Tasha: I think eyelash primer doesn't really matter.
Tasha: 噢
Alice:咋了
Tasha: 它这个胶还可以重复使用
Tasha: This glue can be reused.
Tasha: 这个粘在最边边
Tasha: Stick this on the very edge.
Tasha: 这个粘在中间的那种感觉
Tasha: Stick this in the middle.
Alice:先从中间开始粘
Alice: Start sticking from the middle.
Tasha: 他说不加按夹
Tasha: He said not to press with the curler.
Tasha: 曲线夹
Tasha: Curved curler.
Tasha: 取睫毛不要碰到底部的这个胶条
Tasha: Don't touch the glue strip at the base when picking up the lashes.
Alice:从中间开始贴吧
Alice: Start sticking from the middle.
Alice:我不知道边边在哪
Alice: I don't know where the edge is.
Tasha: 我也不知道
Tasha: I don't know either.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Let's do it.
Tasha: 是不是从下面开始加
Tasha: Should we start from the bottom?
Tasha: 这样子对
Tasha: Like this, right.
Alice:不能从这不能碰到他
Alice: You can't touch it here.
Alice:要不然我们还是用有有胶的吧
Alice: Maybe we should use the one with glue.
Alice:不会用这个
Alice: I can't use this.
Tasha: 失败
Tasha: Failed.
Alice:我有胶
Alice: I have glue.
Tasha: 我也有胶
Alice:你用这个用这个吗
Alice: Are you using this one?
Alice:还挺好用的
Alice: It's pretty good.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Alice:给你推荐一下
Alice: Let me recommend it to you.
Alice:我姐姐是化妆师她就给我推荐这个
Alice: My sister is a makeup artist and she recommended this to me.
Tasha: 哦就挤在这啊
Tasha: Oh, just squeeze it here?
Alice:不是有个什么粘区哦
Alice: Isn't there a sticky area?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:但我没有
Alice: But I don't have it.
Alice:但我刚看到
Alice: But I just saw it.
Alice:一次用3个吗
Alice: Do you use three at a time?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 我就用了一个两个吧
Tasha: I just used one or two.
Tasha: 我说我今天没有用过
Tasha: I said I haven't used it today.
Alice:这是一个眼型哦
Alice: This is for one eye shape.
Tasha: oh
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:但颜色有点太长了
Alice: But the color is a bit too long.
Tasha: 有点多
Tasha: It's a bit much.
Alice:这也太太太明显了
Alice: This is way too obvious.
Alice:太长了
Alice: It's too long.
Tasha: 好你要用你的是吗
Tasha: Okay, you want to use yours?
Alice:用我的吧
Alice: Let's use mine.
Alice:好怕hold不住他
Alice: I'm afraid I can't handle it.
Alice: 我的在哪呢
Alice: Where is mine?
Alice:我用这个
Alice: I'll use this.
Tasha: 嗯这不差不多吗
Tasha: Hmm, isn't this about the same?
Alice:这个要没那么长
Alice: This one isn't as long.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice:那用你的吧
Alice: Then let's use yours.
Tasha: 啊都可以了
Tasha: Ah, either way is fine.
Alice:真的hold不住说实话
Alice: Honestly, I really can't handle it.
Alice:毕竟充满生活地
Alice: After all, it's full of life.
Tasha: 要找什么
Tasha: What are we looking for?
Jake: 笔
Jake: A pen.
Tasha: 我上楼给你拿支笔吧
Tasha: I'll go upstairs and get you a pen.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice:太长了
Alice: It's too long.
Alice:是吧太夸张了
Alice: Right? It's so exaggerated.
Tasha: 不夸张哈哈
Tasha: Not exaggerated, haha.
Alice:不夸张这不夸张吗
Alice: Not exaggerated? Isn't this exaggerated?
Alice:我不敢想象这个出现在我的眼上
Alice: I can't imagine this on my eyes.
Alice:不夸张吗
Alice: Not exaggerated?
Tasha: 啊有点
Tasha: Ah, a bit.
Alice:太夸张了
Alice: It's too exaggerated.
Alice:把它取下来吧
Alice: Let's take it off.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:用我的那个安回去试一下
Alice: Let's try putting mine back on.
Tasha: 还能安回去的是吗
Tasha: Can we put it back on?
Alice:可以OK
Alice: Yes, it's okay.
Alice:要不然你贴一个
Alice: Or you try one.
Alice: 你试一下这个
Alice: You try this one.
Tasha: 就算了吧
Tasha: Never mind.
Tasha: 你要不还在这照没照吧
Tasha: Do you still want to take a picture here?
Alice:也行
Alice: Sure.
Tasha: 好果然每个人都有自己适合的
Tasha: Okay, everyone has something that suits them.
Alice:我i给你也来个
Alice: I'll do one for you too.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 可以好吧
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 真的挺自然的
Tasha: It looks really natural.
Lucia: 吃草莓吗
Lucia: Want some strawberries?
Lucia: 因为我嗯
Lucia: Because I, um...
Tasha: 哈哈不是作为旁观者
Tasha: Haha, not as an onlooker.
Tasha: 而是开始偷偷洗草莓了开始
Tasha: But secretly started washing strawberries, started.
Lucia: 对哈哈哈要吃吗
Lucia: Yeah, haha, do you want some?
Alice:谢谢谢谢
Alice: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 我感觉我开始有点饿了
Lucia: I feel like I'm starting to get a bit hungry.
Tasha: 距离我们吃完早饭
Tasha: Since we finished breakfast...
Tasha: 可能就一个小时
Tasha: It’s probably been just an hour.
Lucia: 我也属于饿的比较快那种类型的
Lucia: I'm also the type that gets hungry quickly.
Tasha: 嗯你贴到哪了
Tasha: Hmm, where did you stick it?
Alice:没贴哪
Alice: Didn’t stick it anywhere.
Tasha: 哦贴三处是吧
Tasha: Oh, you’re sticking three places, right?
嗯
Hmm
Tasha: 你会贴吗
Tasha: Do you know how to stick it?
Lucia: 不会
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 从来没见过
Lucia: Never seen it done.
Tasha: 吃了
Tasha: Ate it.
Alice:应该试水珠子
Alice: Should try water beads.
Tasha: 再贴另一个眼睛
Tasha: Stick it on the other eye.
Alice:我把胶搁哪
Alice: Where did I put the glue?
Alice:如果化一半
Alice: If half the makeup is done...
Alice:饭来了
Alice: Food is here.
Alice: 太尴尬了
Alice: So awkward.
Lucia: 那就民以食为天先吃饭
Lucia: Then let's eat first, food is the most important thing.
Tasha: 多挤点我也来贴一个啊
Tasha: Squeeze out more, I'll stick one too.
Lucia: 你以前贴过吗没有
Lucia: Have you done it before? No.
Tasha: 没有哈哈
Tasha: No, haha.
Alice:来吧来吧
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice:跟我一起
Alice: Do it with me.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:贴吧
Tasha: 不你先贴吧
Tasha: No, you stick it first.
Alice:我快贴好了
Alice: I'm almost done.
Alice:嗯我贴上了下睫毛快
Alice: Hmm, I’ve stuck on the lower lashes quickly.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Alice:你有下睫毛吗
Alice: Do you have lower lashes?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 你要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Alice:这是你的下睫毛吗
Alice: Are these your lower eyelashes?
Tasha: 你要贴吗
Tasha: Do you want to apply them?
Alice:我没有贴过单块的假睫毛
Alice: I've never applied single piece false eyelashes before.
Tasha: 我都没拆开
Tasha: I haven't even opened them.
Lucia: 果然没贴过
Lucia: Of course, you haven't used them.
Lucia: 我饭再不来
Lucia: If my food doesn't come soon,
Lucia: 我就要开始考虑
Lucia: I will start considering
Lucia: 偷吃冰箱里昨天的肯德基了哈哈
Lucia: stealing the KFC from the fridge from yesterday. Haha!
Tasha: 吃吧吃吧
Tasha: Go ahead, eat it.
Lucia: 再等等看
Lucia: Let's wait and see.
Lucia: 啊真奇怪
Lucia: Ah, this is so weird.
Alice:妈呀就这样吧
Alice: Oh dear, let's just go with this.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Okay?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:不要管他了
Alice: Don't worry about it anymore.
Alice:没什么耐心啊
Alice: I'm running out of patience.
Alice:逐渐暴躁啊不要他
Alice: Getting more irritated, let's not use them.
Tasha: 还好我们几个人都不太会化妆
Tasha: Good thing none of us are good at makeup.
Tasha: 我就安心了哈哈哈
Tasha: Now I feel at ease. Haha!
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha!
Lucia: 大家都处于同样的这个起跑线上
Lucia: We're all on the same starting line here.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:起跑线是差不多的
Alice: The starting line is pretty much the same.
Lucia: 帽子好可爱
Lucia: That hat is so cute.
Lucia: 跟你的衣服颜色特别搭配
Lucia: It matches your outfit perfectly.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Alice:睫毛弄在这上面
Alice: The eyelashes got on this.
Lucia: 可以直接在衣服上擦的吗
Lucia: Can you just wipe it on your clothes?
Lucia: 那个这里有纸哈哈
Lucia: There's some tissue here. Haha.
Alice:逐渐暴躁
Alice: Getting more irritated.
Alice:有的时候就手感运气之类的
Alice: Sometimes it's just about the touch and luck.
Alice:我去,真服了